[Music]  I want a venture in the great white  somewhere hello I wanted more than I can  turn into the light for once it might be  around if she is the ones you had fun  I'm just a face to make you Disney's  Beauty and the Beast rated PG well this  castle is alive  the used to take your father's place  comments the light  hello you can talk well of course he  couldn't talk what if she is the one the  one will break the span the Masters not  as terrible as he appears I say we kill  me  think of the one thing you've always  wanted  I feel it in your heart Disney's Beauty  and the Beast  Oh me the girl look at her what if she  is the one the one who break the spell  hello you